it's another flight mayor this Fourth of
July and the Biden Administration is
busy playing the blame game over 40 000
flights have been canceled or delayed
just this week and it's leading to
familiar scenes of frustrated Americans
stranded at airports Nationwide standing
in long lines for hours and even
sleeping on the floors
but don't count on mayor Pete our
secretary of transportation to fix it
he's making excuses for his own travel
issues yeah we got hit with some pretty
tough weather it's affected a lot of
flights I reached my hotel room at about
2 30 in the morning last night after my
flight got canceled and the next one got
delayed a lot of Americans are going
through the same thing what I will say
is that overall we've seen the system
perform much better than it did a year
ago I can't control the weather we've
had very tough weather the last few days
that's definitely being felt through the
system
poor baby
having to get in so late to the hotel
and has ruined himself politically just
by joining this Administration so that's
good I think that this Greg is the East
Palestine of the air waves for him I was
stuck I was delayed going abroad this
week I I was one of the lucky ones
people really are not
leaving they're in the service lines uh
54 billion dollars we gave to the
airlines
to help bail them out to help keep them
going during covid and they were told
not to use it for buyouts but they did
and now when you show up there's no
pilot there's no crew there's no
aircraft many times and I see that these
owners of the airplanes or the people
around the airlines are saying
they're blame the passenger saying pack
some patience and show your ideas if
there's not a pilot and a crew in an
aircraft if you show your driver's
license everything will be better yeah
you know what it is amazing that even if
you the passenger goes the extra mile
like you know I do TSA I do clear I wear
clean underwear I don't get completely
bombed the way I used to I don't hit on
the flight attendants I mean I mind my
own business I listen I pack light I'm
polite you do all of those you tick
every one of those boxes and they still
treat you like you're trying to cross
Donner Pass you know with your with a
barbecue grill you know it's amazing and
maybe it would we cover the story on
tonight and I don't want to give too
much away but Tyrus makes a good point a
lot of this has to do with discount
tickets a lot of people there and it
turns Airline Service agents into
substitute teachers you know dealing
with a class of unruly passengers you
know these the people that are off the
counter and they're just like they got
their arms on the counter and there's
this and they're like they're like me on
Friday but um I do enjoy the travel porn
I like sitting and sitting at home
watching this happen because it's like
you know it's like living in Hawaii and
watching people shovel snow in Buffalo
you just thank God it's not me I mean
Harold let's talk about mayor Pete he is
the Secretary of Transportation on his
watch we've had supply chain crisis
we've had the first shutdown of all air
travel this past early January since 9
11 when he was about 19 years old I
looked it up uh we've had just problem
after problem obviously he's Palestine
you've got to admit at some point even
as a Democrat he's not up to this job
well I like to admit things as an
American and I I I I will agree with you
in this regard I am a Democrat but I'm
an American first
um the people the American people have
lost their sense of humor uh about all
of this uh whether it's East Palestine
whether it's state whether it's Airlines
I don't understand for the life of me
well over the last several years we
don't stress test like we do the banks
the airlines we we have constructed
scenarios very difficult economic
scenarios for the banks to see if they
how they would respond if they have
enough capital in in the bank they have
enough liquidity uh to be able to
shabbat Christmas doesn't sneak up on us
it's December 25th so Fourth of July
doesn't sneak up on us it's July 4th so
you know when there's going to be travel
how we don't test these Airlines to
understand what do they have the
resources to ensure that I've seen
terrible pictures awful pictures of moms
with infants as we uh I thought that
young lady might have been in but
infants in airports having to spend the
night for a day or two there has to be a
better way to do this whether it's East
Palestine where we've yet to articulate
and outline a set of answers whether
it's this we we're short 1500 air
traffic controllers now this has been
something that's built over the years
but why are we not talking about how we
solve this problem before the Fourth of
July pneumatic tubes
pneumatic tubes shoot people through
pneumatic tubes I've been talking about
this for years no one listens to me
shooting them through these tubes you
save so much money you get there faster
Janine in our Administration we tried we
talked about the fact that the air
traffic control system and the whole
travel system was built for about 150
000 passengers a year we now have closer
to a billion we tried to do that through
infrastructure but it sounds like build
back better and other nonsense didn't
work gee isn't that amazing and but when
you say we've lost our sense of humor
you're not talking about the traveler
because last Sunday I had the Uber from
I said this Williamsburg to Richmond
airport that was two hours I stayed at
Richmond airport for two hours they shut
down then I head to Uber from Richmond
to DC and then I waited there for six
hours I ate dinner twice because I
didn't know what else to do you normally
for six of you I'm glad you're having
drugs
and yeah driving what'd you say Driving
Miss Daisy 2023 or Miss crazy all right
um you know what if the FAA cannot staff
uh we got a problem all right they got
billions of dollars this guy bootages is
a local mayor who talks a lot about how
great he is he doesn't know what the
heck he's doing he doesn't even have the
brains to figure out he should go to
Palestine I mean is anybody dumber than
that you've got to admit this guy is
clueless he's talking about the weather
he's talking about everything other than
the fact that he is in charge of this
and when the head of the TSA says bring
your patience I don't want to bring my
patients I paid for TSA I paid for clear
I paid for my ticket I came ahead of
time what else am I supposed to do it's
your job not mine yeah I was sitting
there on Sunday night trying to get to
London watching all the chaos around me
most of the flights were canceled people
200 deep in in the service line at
United Airlines and I'm thinking what
about when the chaos then leads over to
these very serious issues of if you're
if you're if you're short on staff
what's going on with the air traffic
controllers what's going on with the
literally getting the planes not just to
run on time but for us to all feel safe
and come in a system that works well
you're talking about are all the
different factors at play now that gray
does judge and Greg have told us we
won't find them on Spirit Airlines
anytime soon because they're in first
class I know for a fact
no dude judge not flew next to each
other the other day the the here's the
thing right Southwest had scheduling
problems their system was Antiquated all
right United right now has a strike
right they have Staffing problems Delta
had the famous luggage debacle a few
months ago all right airports don't have
enough workers on the tarmac all right
uh the FAA doesn't have enough air
traffic controllers and the TSA doesn't
have enough bodies to run you through
and I know for a fact they they have
different standards for every airport
out there among TSA I will actually say
the TSA here in New York is some of the
best for me
um and so what am I getting at could
there be a government figure whose job
is to regulate these things and make
sure all these different entities with
their different problems and gaps are
communicating and exercising what
problems they have rather than I don't
know a local weather man that's not very
good at this job because that's all I
heard from Pete oh man you know bad
weather and I didn't get in until 2 A.M
you know and he you know like what I
mean I don't get it I don't get it you
have one job is to make sure that all
these entities are communicating with
each other what their problems are and
they all exist on their own Island and
they all have all these debacles it's
not like there's one thing it's one
thing after another I think the moral of
that story is if you can't fill the
potholes in your own small town you're
not going to be able to Be an Effective
Secretary of Transportation hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else